hello grammarians today we're talking
about verbs and bears so we had
previously established at least one
thing about the verb and that was that
it can show actions
but today i'd like to introduce the idea
that the verb can link
ideas to one another in fact we have
this whole class of verbs that we call
linking verbs
or if you want to call it something
fancier we call that state of being
verbs
these linking verbs include all forms of
the verb to be which i have handily
written out for you so i am he is we are
be nice they were being they have been
he was we were
now we use a linking verb when we want
to connect one idea to another so what
i'm going to do is i'm going to divide
the screen in half between the action
side and the state of being side just to
show you
what i mean
so we use action verbs to show what
something
does
whereas we use state of being verbs to
show what something
is
so let's bring it back to this bear
let's think of an action for this bear
to do what is a bear-like thing to do
the bear eats a fish
that's an action that's something the
bear is doing
the bear is hungry however is not
something that the bear is doing it's
something that the bear is so what is is
doing here is connecting the word hungry
to the word bear
it's linking it
some verbs can be used both ways they
can be used both as actions and as
linking verbs and i'll show you an
example of that
you could say the bear looked at me
which is to say the bear is doing a
thing looking at something namely me but
we could also say using the same verb
the bear looked lonely
now in this case this is describing
how the bear looks
what the bear looks like
this looking is not something the bear
is doing it is how the bear appears to a
viewer
so
looked
is connecting
lonely
to bear it is linking lonely to barrett
as a linking verb
by the same token we could say for an
action the bear smells a person what is
it smelling a person
but we could also say the bear smells
like cinnamon which i grant you is
pretty unlikely don't go smelling bears
but what what smells is doing here is
connecting the idea of cinnamon to the
bear
the bear isn't smelling cinnamon the
bear smells like cinnamon and that's the
difference between a linking verb and an
action verb as a linking verb shows what
something is an action verb shows what
something does
so the bear is hungry the bear looked
lonely the bear smells like cinnamon
these all reflect something about what
the bear is how it's being
you can learn anything dave it out